budget
aura 100 milliards de plus pour l'armée
pour les investissements nécessaires
dans les équipements
d'année en année nous passerons à plus
de 2 % de notre pib
pour notre défense
cet objectif ils ne posaient pas
simplement parce que nous avons nos
obligations avec nos alliés
d'augmenter à 2% tous ces
investissements mais nous le faisons
aussi pour nous pour notre sécurité
voilà pour cette déclaration du
chancelier allemand olaf chose pour en
apprendre plus on prend tout de suite la
direction de berne injustement où nous
attend le correspondant de france 24
nick spicer bonjour nique nique eux on
l'a compris c'est un changement majeur
dans la ligne politique allemand dans
ses annonces
ah c'est sûr et certain je suis
peut-être une demi kilomètre
ou en fait c'est la fin je veux pas dire
la fin du pacifisme allemand mais c'est
la fin de cette tradition de
l'ostpolitik
ou l'allemagne et c'est par le dialogue
d'établir une entente avec la la russie
d'adoucir rappelé les relations
diplomatiques et d'éviter la guerre
c'est la détente de la garonne tout cela
renferme quelque sorte alors que la
porte reste ouverte au dialogue les
allemands ont décidé de vendre des armes
de d'envoyer des armes en ukraine
commune et de le dire et ça c'est ça
c'est vraiment nouveau parce que
jusqu'ici c'était un tabou les allemands
dans le dernier sondage qui étaient
conduits avant l'invasion de l'ukraine
était à 68 % à s'y opposer maintenant
c'est un fait accompli on envoie des
mines antichars des 1000 solaire en
ukraine a beaucoup de pétrole pour les
pour les chars ukrainien et donc c'est
un revirement très important et il faut
souligner que ces 100 milliards c'est
ces nouvelles dépenses seront enchâssées
dans la constitution d'après midi hier
du chancelier allemand
nick vous êtes on l'aperçoit derrière
vous dans l'est dans les rues de berlin
où des dizaines de milliers de personnes
se sont rassemblées ce dimanche pour
dénoncer l'invasion russe de l'ukraine
et vous avez pu suivre cette
mobilisation
voilà je suis devant l'ambassade russe
ou voilà peut-être le drapeau tricolore
qui flotte au-dessus de larmes à sable
et donc il y avait devant l'ambassade
d'egypte craignant des russes une
fanfare qui jouait l'hymne national
ukrainien à répétition il ya des rires
des larmes beaucoup de genres très ému
il y a des gens vraiment de toutes
sortes ici de tous les âges des familles
qui sont venues les parents qui m'ont
dit que l'on voulait pas de guerre pour
leurs enfants ce qui ce qui est tout à
fait compréhensible et gens qui étaient
là tous sens pour ce lieu en solidarité
pour l'ukraine certains qui étaient
contre l'idée de livrer des arbres qui
m'ont dit en fait ça ne servait à rien
il n'était pas content de cette idée
d'avoir une rupture dans la tradition
pacifiste allemand mais tous étaient
pour que l'on vienne en aide aux
ukrainiens et je peux vous dire
également que la deutsche bahn et la
sncf allemande vient d'annoncer que tous
les réfugiés une craie niaque qui
atteignent la frontière pour le nesc
pourront voyager avec leurs documents en
ukrainien gratuitement à berlin où ils
pourront demander l'asile
merci beaucoup unique spicer
correspondant france 24